[Music]
hey friends
today we're gonna have some fun we're
gonna do a bit of a showdown
uh between the beautiful renaissance
loot here and the
classical guitar so i chose a piece
which was originally written for the
loot
but today is frequently played by
classical guitarists
that piece is the la creme pavone by
john dowland john dowland was an
incredible
english loot virtuoso and during his
lifetime
this piece became extraordinarily
popular and then it was very popular for
an extraordinary amount of time it
exists in
many versions and has been arranged for
everything from
loot and voice to a vile consort with
loot
to keyboards it was just so loved that
people wanted to play on every possible
instrument
so i guess it's no surprise that
guitarists today have made it a part
of their standard repertoire but of
course it was indeed originally written
for the loot around 1595
is the earliest version of which we're
aware but there are
many many additions of english luke
books
and even loot books from abroad in which
this piece
appears and while there are recordings
of guitarists who've played this piece
and lewdness who played this piece you
don't really ever hear one person who
plays it
on each instrument so i thought we could
do just that today
now although historically these
instruments aren't directly related
they do share a pretty similar tuning
which makes it possible to play loot
music so easily on the guitar both of
these instruments are tuned
in perfect fourths most the strings are
tuned in fourths and there is one
major third in the middle and of course
if you look at the peg box
you'll quickly see that there are many
more strings on the loot
than there are the six string guitar but
we have to remember a few
things first every string on the loot is
doubled except for the first one
the chanterelle which you can learn more
about if you can watch my
video introducing the loops but we play
each of those pairs the choruses
as one and in fact in the early
renaissance
six chorus loots were common and indeed
this piece the locker rape vivant was
first published around 1595
for a six course loot so since choruses
are played as one
string really that's basically a guitar
all we have to do
is take the third string and tune it
down a half step and then we actually
have
the nominal tuning of a six course loot
and then the actual playing of the
instrument is quite similar
to the loot and we can indeed read
directly from
manuscripts from the renaissance period
which is what i'll be doing today
also i should mention my loots in g
but tuned at 4 15 at the moment meaning
that when i play
a g minor chord it actually sounds as a
g
flat minor chord everything's tuned down
a half step
so that means to have the same pitches
on my guitar i'm going to grab my capo
and put a capo on the second fret
tune that third string down
[Music]
a half step and now i have a loot
now for the showdown i'm going to use my
torres copy
which is a late 19th century style
guitar
made by sayers guitars again in loop
tuning
so i have a capo so i'm at the same
pitch i have gut strings
and i have no nails on the loot i also
have gut strings
on the first two courses and then i have
synthetic guts
for the rest on both instruments i'll be
using
late renaissance loop technique which is
basically
pinky down playing close to the bridge
and with a thumb out technique so this
position rather than the earlier loop
position
which is this it's possible that darwin
would have been playing
thumb out like this which is actually
not too dissimilar from the modern
classical guitar position
except for the pinky down and playing
without nails
one extra thing you should know is that
although i played both these instruments
i've been playing the guitar
a lot longer and so while i'm using loot
technique
on both of them and got strings i'm
quite a bit more
friendly and experienced with the guitar
and so perhaps my loot playing hasn't
caught out with my guitar playing yet
so i'm going to do my best let's hear
the opening a section
on the loot and then the guitar
[Music]
do
[Music]
this is such a beautiful piece and i
really think it sounds lovely
on both instruments when i listen to the
loot version what i love so much
is how silvery and bright and
maybe introspective is the right word
that the loot comes across
it's so charming then when the guitar
started i don't know about you but
it sounds so warm and bassy
in comparison to the loot that i'm
immediately struck
by its warmth and resonance and since
i'm playing without nails it's even
more warm in resonance and i think when
i went back to listen to the loot again
the loot sounded a little bit banjoey to
me
um but you know after 20 seconds or so
listen to the loot i think it pulls you
into its beautiful
silvery world and i don't think of it as
sounding thin i think of it as sounding
perfect as is it's just relative to the
guitar it's obviously
brighter and i think the loot's
brightness helped
actually in this piece this is a
contrapuntal piece
meaning there are many independent
moving parts
and on the loot it's so transparent you
can hear everything the guitar is so
bassy and warm that actually i found it
kind of
muddy let's listen to some more this is
the
first variation of the a section
[Music]
do
[Music]
we can hear there are one advantages of
the loot it can have more bass strings
currently i have this loot as strong as
a seven course which means
i have an extra low note that isn't on
the guitar
so those cadences i can not only just do
this
but i get to go
with that beautiful low d and you can
see in some of the manuscript versions
of this piece that some people were
using seven course loots and they were
using that low d
but the first edition doesn't have it so
that's one thing i really like about
the loot version i get to use that low
octave which sounds so beautiful
also if you're enjoying this showdown
don't forget to like and subscribe here
it really helps
uh help my channel grow another thing
i'm hearing and i i wonder if you're
hearing it too is that the loot
has a bit of a thicker sound in terms of
the amount of notes
because there are literally more there's
kind of a chorusy effect
because all the strings are doubled
again except for the first
[Music]
the rest like my second string has two
d's played as
one which kind of gives the effect of a
chorus you know two singers
singing the same note at the same time
so i hear that thickness
whereas on the guitar it just sounds
like one
simpler note so the guitar version
sounds a bit simpler maybe
two-dimensional
where the loot version sounds almost
three-dimensional to me with
more notes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
so maybe i'm biased here because i play
both instruments but
i think there's really something to love
about both versions
they really sound different um
extraordinarily different to my ears
and they feel so different to play the
loot
is smaller the loot has a bowl back
which is a completely different way
of resonating inside the chamber whereas
the guitar of course
is an hourglass shape with a flat back
and they just resonate differently so
when you play it it feels different
of course the different sizes another
big difference is that
the strings on loots are so much looser
they're much lower attention i can
really wiggle them
which means that ornaments are so easy
whereas the strings are more taut on a
classical guitar and even though i put
low tension gut strings on here it's
still quite taut
in comparison to the loot
but again here i have to say i'm torn
i'm not really sure in this showdown who
won
uh my gut wants to say that the the
original instrument for which it was
written
has to have some authenticity you know
that gives us some credit here but
let me know in the comments what did you
like better and why
by the way if you're interested in
learning the locker mate pavan i just
did a 40 minute video for tone bass
in which i do a deep dive into the
history
and interpretation and how to ornament
this
wonderful work so i'd recommend heading
over to their website where they have
all these incredible tutorials by some
of the world's best guitarists
so thanks so much for watching and stay
tuned because i'm going to release
the full video of me playing the loot
version and the full video of me playing
the guitar version so they can be
enjoyed on their own merits
see you guys next time
you